aber welche auf jeden fall ich kann mich
noch daran zurück erinnern ich war
glaube ich sechzehn meine freundin war
und wir waren so glücklich hey leute was
glaubt bereits bekommen beim ein video
ja heute ich hoffe euch geht's gut
gestern kamen wir endlich unser
riesenprojekt aus dem spanien online
also wenn ist noch nicht gesehen habt
kann ich euch nur ans herz legen welches
noch anzuschauen also mein letztes video
war auf jeden fall eine menge arbeit
deswegen ich wette es lohnt sich auch
für euch das mal anzuschauen ich will
aber eigentlich auch gar nicht
eingeladen am anfang das letzte jungs
mädchen thema an liegt jetzt schon
wieder einige zeit in der vergangenheit
ja ich hab nur so glaube ich vor
ungefähr einer woche oder fünf tagen mal
die trends gesehen in deutschland und da
ist mir so ein video ins auge stoßen und
dass sie ist irgendwie so tatsachen von
männern oder jungs die mädchen oder
frauen gar nicht so wirklich bewusst
sind und es war recht weit oben und ich
habe mir gedacht komm schaust du dir
jetzt mal kurz an ging auch nur drei
minuten und ich saß da sofort dachte mir
so zum einen war es auf jeden fall echt
langweilig und zum anderen habe ich
gedacht das ist alles so richtig richtig
krass auf vorurteile bezogen und ich
dachte mir so vielleicht kannst ja mal
in dem du dich so ein bisschen weiter
zurück hält also nicht so weit aus dem
fenster lehnt wie dies in dem video
gemacht haben weil wir sind zu diesem
thema auch wirklich sofort so dinge
eingefallen die ich halt dazu sagen
würde
und da hab ich mir jetzt 34 ausgesucht
ich habe das video jetzt wie folgt
aufgebaut also erst kommen so ein paar
punkte die mehrheit sofort ein gefallen
sind und dann kommen weitere punkte die
ich noch im internet gefunden hat also
im großen und ganzen geht es heute um 10
tatsachen von jungs die mädchen
überhaupt nicht bewusst sind so ungefähr
ja leute plötzlich gefällt doch nach
oben wir fangen jetzt an
und jetzt also folgende x 1 das erste
was mir als sofort eingefallen ist und
zwar könnt ihr euch bestimmt alle mega
gut in die situation hineinversetzen
jetzt mal als beispiel ihr als mädchen
als frau hat einen freund und seid euch
gar nicht zu sicher sollte jetzt heute
abend diese frisur oder diese frisur
besser halt präsentieren wird auch immer
oder diese schuhe oder diese schuhe
anziehen und die meisten so kenne ich
das halt auch wandern oft mal so dem
freund hier soll das anziehen soll ich
das sind sie nur das anziehen nur das
ding ist halt meistens klar wir würden
euch echt gerne beraten aber so wirklich
so dass bessere zu finden also so ein
unterschied zwischen den dingen
fällt mir dann fast nie auf und das
problem ist dann halt auch wenn ich dann
zum beispiel sagen würde komm nimm doch
das dann nimmt sie aber das andere weil
das schöner ist aus ihren augen das ist
halt eine tatsache also fragt uns am
besten gar nicht natürlich habe ich
glaube ich auch echt schon richtig gut
beraten aber aber ich würde schätzen
dass tritt so vielleicht bei fünf von
hundert fällen ein so können wir zur
nächsten sache die mir auch relativ
schnell noch eingefallen ist und zwar
kennt ihr das wahrscheinlich auch und
zwar geht es ums lästern
also natürlich lässt seine männer auch
viel aber ich glaube frauen setzen dem
ganzen öfter mal vor allem wenn diese
unter sich sind noch so ein krönchen auf
jahren was ich jetzt sagen möchte also
als beispiel widerhallt freund und
freundin und die freundin regt sich als
total über ihre freundin auf von der die
freundinnen von der der freund was auch
immer und da war ich halt so durchgeht
und dieser letzte reihe voll und man
liegt daran so wahrscheinlich kennt man
die meistens auch kaum man versucht zwar
netterweise dem ganzen noch zuzuhören
aber im endeffekt ist es glaube ich den
meisten so was von scheißegal ging ganz
schön gemein gerade glaub ich egal
kommen wir zum nächsten sache das ist
mir vor mich wann war ich das letzte mal
feiern ich glaube sofort drei tagen also
vor allem dann fällt mir das immer auf
natürlich kann es dann auch daran liegen
weil viele halt alkohol im blut haben
und so weiter aber die meisten jungs
oder männer hat gehen halt auf toilette
gehen an pisten oder was auch immer
gehen dann raus indem sie einfach
ausgehen also ich würd mal schon zu
schätzen
jeder dritte junge lässt sich nicht die
hände vielleicht ist auch nur jeder
vierte oder jeder fünfte aber etwas
machen so wenige manchmal ich denke mir
warum die ja das einzige wo ich mir
nicht die hände wasche ist wenn ich auch
so eine eklige autobahnraststätte fahre
dann halt in diese öffentlichen teile
reichen die halt nicht geputzt werden
und dann bin ich da so schnell wie
möglich da raus und will nicht auf
dieses eklige waschbecken anpassen weil
ich meinen mann fast ja eh nix an warum
sollte man sich dann die anderen nur
weil man seinen eigenen aber was ich mir
dann aber auch noch raus geschrieben
habe das war glaube ich sogar in diesem
video also wenn ein junge oder ein mann
auf die steht dann muss man das
eigentlich merken weil ich glaube männer
sind dann ein bisschen anders als frauen
dass sie das wirklich
jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt zeigen
wollen aber sie zeigen
ich weiß nicht ob mir mich da versteht
aber das sehe ich halt irgendwie auch
sogleich beziehe ich das jetzt auch mal
auf mich selber dass wenn ich mal so
über meine handlungsweise nachdenken wie
man so zum beispiel mal geschrieben hat
oder geredet hat das ist dann irgendwie
so logisch sein müsste oder das halt die
frau das dann checken müsste also das
war die einzige sache aus dem video wo
ich zugestimmt habe schlaue leute und
jetzt kommt's mir aber eigentlich zu
einem witzigen part dieses videos ich
habe mir noch so 56 sachen raus
geschrieben aus dem internet also
tatsachen von männern die frau nicht
bewusst sind und die sind echt ganz
lustig auch nie eine sache die ich auch
auf jeden fall noch sagen wollte
also man sagt ja immer die nase eines
mannes so auch sein johannes bestimmt
nicht das stimmt wirklich auf keinen
fall ich meine wenn man schaut
ich habe eigentlich so jetzt keine
kleine nase aber ich habe so eine
normale nase das da ist aber nicht noch
mal so und jetzt machen wir weiter mit
tatsachen aus dem internet in einem raum
voller frauen fühlen sich männer total
wohl umgekehrt ist das aber nicht der
fall halter werden darauf gekommen also
ich weiß nicht ob sich dieser tatsache
jetzt alle frauen bewusst sind
aber das stimmt wirklich kaum zu glauben
aber es stimmt also ich würde das auf
jeden fall genauso sehen 44 prozent der
männer warten nach dem ersten date drei
tage bis sie sich melden sie denken
davor sei es uncool
ich weiß jetzt zwar nicht wenn ihr da
gefragt habt aber 44 prozent ist schon
extrem viel ich mein stell dir vor so
nach drei tagen hatte ich doch schon
fast vergessen drei tag das sind 72
stunden durch glaube ich mich mit
jemandem getroffen und die hätte ich mir
dann so drei tage danach erst wieder
geschrieben steht gefragt wer bist du
überhaupt von den ganzen mit denen ich
mich jetzt so über die zeit getroffen
habt versteht ihr was ich meine
das war jetzt natürlich nur spaß also
ich würde da jetzt vielleicht mal so 5
prozent tippen aber doch nicht 44 männer
sind im durchschnitt am glücklichsten in
beziehung mit sechs jahre jüngeren
partnerin ja welche auf jeden fall
ich kann mich noch daran zurück erinnern
ich war da glaube ich sechzehn meine
freundin war 10
und wir waren so glücklich nun also das
war nicht so eine schöne zeit hier spaß
also klar bezieht sich das dann
wahrscheinlich eher auf ältere ob das
jetzt stimmt oder nicht
wie will kann das herausfinden aber auf
jeden fall richtig coole studien und was
ich auch noch gefunden habt der richtige
spitzname jungs wollen am liebsten
schatz genannt werden gefolgt von deep
link
und tiernamen gehen gar nicht hat
parship mein bärchen mein tiger ja ich
glaube das trifft schon ganz gut so
schatz ist immer gut ja leute wollen was
mal hier bei belassen ihr könnt ja mal
in die kommentare schreiben
wie nennt ihr euren partner am liebsten
ist das eher schatz oder baby oder
vielleicht irgendwo name aus dem zoo
schreibt in die kommentare gibt da nach
oben wenn sich gefallen hat man gucken
aber 12.000 like schaffen steigt auf
jeden fall snapshot und instagram 8
folgt auf jeden fall auf snapshot bei
morgen brauche ich euch darum wir sehen
uns wahrscheinlich schon morgen wieder
haut rein vergesse ich das video von
gestern anzuschauen und peace